et à paris une manifestation en soutien
ou semaine sont qu a lieu en ce moment
même sur place on y retrouve notre
reporter thomas boni thomas bonjour à
l'heure des membres de la diaspora
sénégalaise enfants sont tenu à apporter
leur soutien aux manifestants
quelle est l atmosphère sur place
ok ils font plusieurs centaines est très
rassemblée depuis une heure maintenant
sur cette place de la république avec
des slogans vous pouvez l'imaginer des
slogans hostiles au président sénégalais
macky sall macky sall démission macky
sall dégage voilà ce qu on entend assez
régulièrement et puis les manifestants
ont tout à l'heure à observer une minute
de silence en posant un genou à terre
pour rendre hommage aux manifestants qui
ont perdu la vie ces derniers jours dans
les rues jeu légal lors de ces
manifestations fortement réprimées par
le pouvoir alors évidemment il demande
la libération des prisonniers et en
premier desquelles celle de ousmane
sacko qui est en garde à vue au moins
jusqu'à ce dimanche et qui sera présenté
à un juge ce lundi pour lé été arrêté
pour trouble à l'ordre public tous ici
ne sont pas forcément des partisans de
ousman sonko à la base mais ils tiennent
à ce que la démocratie au sénégal reste
protégé et ils s'inquiètent justement
des reculs démocratiques en cours dans
le pays propose d'écouter quelques unes
de leurs réactions ces micro de massy
sardos
apportez moi je suis pas son coup mais
je marocain el cheikh anta aujourd'hui
qu'en 2011
notre démocratie est mise àl'épreuve
parle pas un régime dictatorial et nous
les sénégalaises apporter notre soutien
regroupe aujourd'hui au contraire au
dictateur au président qui la complicité
du ministre avec la complicité des deux
buts et qu'on se laisse enfin on se
laissera pas faire et qu'aujourd'hui
encore on sera là on sera là tous les
week-ends tant que ce pouvoir ne
libérera pas tous les détenus politiques
le sénégal c'est une démocratie macky
sall et il n'a pas été du pouvoir il n'a
pas hérité le pouvoir mais ses parents
ni de ses origines hélas il y là il y là
il est enseigné à oran pouvoir
démocratiquement c'est le peuple qui l'a
élu
donc elle a respecté cette démocratie
maintenant nous le peuple quant aux
ventes à la démocratie demeure bafoué le
peuple opprimé la justice kidnappé le
résistance ne peut dire du pacifique
donc on va se donner corps et âme
d'arrache-pied vous sauver notre
démocratie est la préserver en
échangeant avec les manifestants on
comprend que la contestation dépasse la
personnalité d'ousmane son côté plus
généralement la gestion de la crise
ducobu 19 par exemple ou encore les
reculs démocratiques au sénégal qui sont
la cause de cette contestation notamment
porté donc par la jeunesse du pays et
puis évidemment le fait de manifester
ici à paris c'est aussi une forme de
message pour les gouvernements
occidentaux et pour emmanuel macron
certains accusent la france notamment
d'une certaine forme de complicité avec
à l'élite du pays avec notamment
l'exploitation des ressources naturelles
au sénégal merci thomas pour toutes ces
précisions